Superman to the adventure continues with  the three Dylan's from Krypton each one  with the same powers as Superman each  one dedicated to violence against  mankind I think of it three super  villains or fourth accounting twice the  adventure continues in palace with Lois  Lane  I believe this is your floor and the  romance continues  the adventure continues in Washington  the world is on the brink of destruction  Superman can you hear me  and the troubles is influence is there  no one on this planet to even challenge  me  Superman general would you care to step  outside  Benj revenge revenge  you know we're cooking  big ones just as strong as Superman if  you've only seen the first part you  haven't seen the best part  the adventure continues in the Superman  2  you